la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de dijon a ordonné ce matin
l'ouverture d'un supplément
d'information avant de statuer
définitivement sur le sort de christine
villemin celle ci fut inculpé de
l'assassinât de son fils grégory c'était
au mois de juillet 1985
grégory villemin fut découvert mort je
vous le rappelle dans la rivière la
vologne le 16 octobre 1984
ce supplément d'information n'est pas
mince 450 pages sur les 3500 du dossier
d'instruction rédigé par le juge lambert
sont à refaire
c'est un peu un camouflet pour le juge à
dijon reportage isabelle beige clair
noël alexandre c'est une nouvelle
lecture que maurice simon le président
de la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de dijon propose aujourd'hui de
l' affaire villemin non seulement
christine villemin n'est plus la seule
suspecte à ses yeux non seulement le
président simon envisage de rouvrir la
piste laroche souvenez-vous le premier
suspect tué depuis par jean marie
villemin
mais encore selon lui le petit garçon
n'aurait pas été tuée à l'heure à
laquelle l'instruction du juge lambert
s'arrêtait le président simon suggère
que l'enfant aurait pu mourir vers 20
heures et non plus vers 17h10 les 19
minutes prêté par le juge lambert à
christine villemin pour commettre le
crime dans le village voisin et rentrer
à la maison ne signifierait donc plus
rien c'est d'ailleurs un chronométrage
que la défense avait toujours contesté
pour nous cet arrêt doucement posément
s'achemine vers la solution que nous
espérons et que nous avons toujours
espéré et qui nous paraît être celle de
la justice à savoir le non lieu pour
madame christine villemin cependant les
magistrats de dijon relève toujours dit
charge contre christine parmi lesquels
cette expertise en écriture qui la
désignent comme le corbeau est également
les témoignages de ses collègues qui
affirme l'avoir vu le jour du crime
poster une lettre à l'heure précise où
le corbeau aurait envoyé celle qui
revendiquait le meurtre de l'enfant